SIDE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
WITH A HEAVY SPIN AND LOOK AT
THE POWER.
THE CELTICS ARE  SWINGS.
NOW IT IS TATUM.
TATUM GOING HARD.
TATUM HAS TO
IS ONE CALL THUS FAR THAT WE
HAVE KIND OF TURNEDD JAMESF THE
SPIN
I'M GOING ONE WAY.
I'M
OFF AS MUCH, BUT I DO FEEL TO
CELTICS HAS BEEN GOOD IN EVERY
WILLIAMS KEPT IT ALIVE, AND IT
WAS LAS
TATUMR, AND
WITH 22 NOW.
TATUM AGAINST BERTANS.  COMES.
DIFFERENCE.
THE
HESITATI TATUM.
TATUM THROWS IT DOWN.
YOU DONFINDS TATUM.TATUM STEPBA.
JAYSON TATUM WITH 20 POINTS ON .
DEFENDERS, AND LAYS IT
>> Mike: TATUMTHREE-POINT SHOT.
THERE IS JAYSON TATUM  AT
SC
TATUM.M.
TATUMS BENZOATE, NICELY DONE.
LOOK AT
TATUM FALLAWAY
THIS ONE RIGHT HERE, SPIN,GET I
ROTATION.THAT STEP  FEW YEARS A
WITHWELL.
THEY HAVE A LOT O OOFF THE DRIB
COME ON.
>> Justin:
THE WIWITEAM FOUL.
TATUM HESITATION AND HE GOESPOI
OFF.
KNOCKS IT GRANT WILLIAMS BUT WAK
-- WATCH WHY HE GETS THE
FOOL.
ALDRIDGE
HERE WE GO.
TATU
TATUM, DRIVES ON WESTBROOK,
BEGINS, TO
GUY CAN SCORE FROM.
THE ADDED IN TRANSITION.
SHOWING TRANSITION.  11 WITH
3: